hello everybody and welcome to part
eight of our Python with n ltk for
natural language processing tutorial
video in this video we're gonna be
talking about limit izing so what is
limit izing so limit izing is a very
similar operation to stemming only the
end result is a real word ok so the end
result will be generally your route stem
is going to be some form of synonym or
it might be the same word but some form
of synonym to the original word so you
might end up with a very different word
but it'll be it'll be a similar word
with the same meaning so for example
let's go ahead and go from NLT KDOT stem
import word net lemma tiser now we'll
say lemon tiser equals word net lemma
tiser and let's just print some examples
really quick so we're going to do print
lemma tiser lemma ties and first let's
limit eyes cats it gets limit eyes to
cat now let's do a few more
cats will do cacti geese looks like
these geese rocks Python let's try this
again we've ruined okay so cat becomes
cat cat tae becomes cactus geese becomes
goose rocks become rock and then just a
singular Python becomes Python okay
so that's cool now what about what if we
did let's limit eyes better let's just
try this first see what it comes up with
better but what if we said better and
then I think it's POS equals and then
better uh this is an adjective
let's try that okay so it actually comes
back with a completely different word
which is good so then let's say fast and
then just to save time since every time
we will load this it run a run can
actually be a noun like test run and
then let's do run verb so go a few
examples here
so best goes the best run goes to run
run as a verb still goes to run so at
least with best best was a decent
example of a word that becomes something
totally different artists are not best
better better is the one that became a
different word so by default some people
get confused with limit izing because
they'll throw run like they'll do
something like this so for example
better as an adjective came back too
good but what if we did what if we got
rid of POS is a wait a moment and we get
back a return of better okay that's not
what we what we expected now that we
know that that's not what we're supposed
to expect so the default parameter for
limit eyes is going to be POS equals
noun so if you have something that is
not a noun you have to pass through the
part of speech tag so keep that in mind
when you limit eyes things but anyway
limit izing is going to be better in my
opinion in stemming because it's going
to give you an actual word a word with a
meaning and it will actually group a lot
of words together and it does a better
job I think than stemming those but
stemming is still useful and it's
something if you're going to be intent
natural language processing you probably
should know what stemming is so no
regrets teaching it but I do think limit
izing is going to be so much more
powerful so anyways that's just a real
quick example of limit izing you'll find
that yulia's Lamas way more often I
think so if you have any questions or
comments anything confusing I know these
three lines are just brutal uh let me
know post your comments below